sunday is a season 6 finale of the
award-winning series homeland which is
more than 5 million viewers Emmy
nominated actor Rupert Friend stars as
former CIA operative Peter Quinn now the
character you remember barely survived a
gas poisoning in a series stroke last
season people thought he wasn't going to
make it but he did here's a preview the
finale you will see only on CBS this
morning
[Music]
ok I know your service guys catch me
when you're inside how about you are you
going to be that team of deltas be
careful playing you to carry homeland
Arizona Showtime which as you know is a
division of CBS Rupert Friend joins us
once again at the table good morning to
you Rupert morning this has certainly
been Peter Quinn season I think this
year thank you and Quinn is quite cute
don't you think
very very cute it's really cold on your
acting yes it really has how did you
prepare to probably the condition that
you're playing um it was a lot of
research and you know there's there's a
lot out there actually by people on
YouTube on the internet who have been
the victim of a stroke and there's
plenty of people who have posted kind of
help me videos where they're sharing
within their community ways of doing
fairly everyday tasks like having a bath
for example how do you do that when you
can't use one of your arms no imaginary
Bradley Cooper on Elephant Man on stage
it was amazing to watch his
transformation don't you think Troy it
reminds me of that when I watch you on
homeland yeah thank you yeah it was a it
was a real journey to go on with
somebody that I feel very close to do
you think everybody wants your character
and Kari to have some love up there yes
I sounds like you do Charlie where are
your finding for it yes I am your pro
love at this table yeah yeah prologues
really I said the same thing to him in
the greenroom he goes you said that to
me last time
these Duncanson so they changed it yes
that's right more sympathetic that's
right you did a lot of research on sarin
gas isn't it interesting to see what's
happening in the news Rupert it's
terrifying I'm you know I had to again
research the effects of sarin gas very
closely for the finale of last season
and it's really terrifying to see these
and very difficult to watch children
suffering from something that itit does
to their by yeah it's horrific horrific
that's part of it because in the season
finale
you survived a sarin gas attack here in
that chamber yeah and that's why you
suffered the stroke that's right and
then Quinn gets woken from the stroke by
carry too in an attempt to get
information that he doesn't have and in
so waking him up he suffers a brain
hemorrhage so by the time he's back to
consciousness he's semi-paralyzed
suffering from aphasia and mental and
physical impairment but you're a
returning veteran that's right something
that means something to you yeah looking
at your notes I'm trying to figure out
what that is well I just in them in the
car in the morning after seeing these
strikes I just remembered you know in
some of my research I was reading the
poems of Wilfred Owen secret Sassoon and
first world war poets who'd shot
suffered from PTSD and I think that
veterans are severely underserved as a
demographic by our society and I just
wanted to just read 20 seconds of sure
opponent if I'm a cook you'll see at
decora mest pro patria mori which means
sweet and honorable it is to die for
your country and the ends like this if
in some smothering dreams you too could
pace behind the wagon that we flung him
in and watch the white eyes writhing in
his face his hanging face like a devil's
sick of sin if you could hear at every
jolt the Blood come gargling from the
froth-corrupted lungs obscene as cancer
bitter as the cud of vile incurable
sores on innocent tongues my friend you
would not tell with such high zest to
children ardent for some desperate glory
the old lie dulce at the core amassed
pro patria mori
what is that touch you sir I just think
that the horrors of war are still with
us 100 years
after this was written and it makes me
incredibly sad that we continue to do
terrible things to other each other to
innocent people in particular not ask
you about the season finale which airs
this weekend the the co-creator Alex
Gansa said everything is going to become
a little clearer after you watch them
finale yes so what's going to happen the
finale for me is all about revealing
people's true characters we're going to
see the mettle of the president
incumbent we're going to see the metal
of Quinn the mettle of Harry and Saul
and dar Adal and all of these people
we've come to know and perhaps not love
in certain cases but to see what they
really made them well that's so well
that make me want to watch yeah that's a
very good teeth and you're known for
thank you all of your own stunts that
continues for you to you like that
that is true yeah and it's resulted in
one or two injuries this season I
managed to break my foot I had a squib
go off in my face which was like an
explosive device over blood okay I burnt
my face and got shot by a stray bullet
casing so it was a busy season but you
love your job I do
we love you Rupert thank you very much
good to have you lovely to be here the
season 6 finale of homeland air Sunday
on Showtime